the weather's from Watcher Guru First
Republic Bank expected to be seized by
U.S government wow First Republic Bank
is expected to be seized by the U.S
government report by Fox Business
Network says according to Charles
gasparino Bankers working with First
Republic say they expect eventual
government receivership of the for the
LA Bank this will come after it exhausts
private sector Solutions such as asset
sales and finding a buyer both of which
appear difficult not surprised First
Republic lost more than 40 percent of
its deposits approximately 72 billion
dollars in the first quarter of this
year holy crap that's bad its shares
sank nearly 50 percent as the end of
Tuesday this is according to a Monday
Announcement by the bank the bank has
seen record drops over the past month
and a half particularly since the
Silicon Valley bank was closed in March
multiple big banks have also struggled
however it looks like First Republic
will be falling into the hands of the
U.S government soon
uh they're also they're going to be
doing that Central Bank digital currency
in June or something I heard about that
so this is all like kind of good timing
what if this is what precipitates an
emergency buyout we were talking about
this the last time there was a bank in
crisis which was like three weeks ago
and uh so yeah and the idea is like the
banks start crumbling then the US
government steps in and says we are
going to rescue your deposits good
members of First Republic Bank simply
download the FED app and we will convert
your US Dollars into fed coin which you
can then use to purchase Goods
I'll tell you guys if that happens
because I'm this whole discussion is
stressing me out I'm experiencing some
existential angst because that's my bank
that's my that's my bank uh that I Bank
in it's also the bank that owns the
mortgage for my house well that well
that might be good news it might be I
have no idea like who am I cool you know
we've got direct deposits going into
this Bank we've got like I just told my
we just learned about this what like
half an hour ago or something yeah I
told my wife we don't know what's
happening with our money I mean we're
well under the FDIC cap so we'll get
insured for that but to be fair you've
had like a month to prepare for this
because we knew First Republic was in
Dire Straits I believe their PR
statements they're like we're secure I
actually think that I mean I don't know
anything about this but I do think that
they're just taking backsplash from what
happened with Silicon Valley Bank so I
kind of doubt that this is a fundamental
issue with a bank I think that this is
part of the panic which is a reason why
I should have joined the panic and taken
my money out myself or maybe by not
panicking you may have helped them yeah
but they lost 40 percent of the deposits
yeah I mean that sounds like
mismanagement they're being sued
apparently but but hold on right there a
minute wouldn't it be cool to wake up
everybody listen you wake up one day and
you get a phone call and they're like
you know that mortgage you had in your
house it's gone it's just yours for
three hundred thousand dollars actually
during the in 2009 during the the
banking crisis with a financial crisis
was when I bought my first house in LA
and I had this experience I've never
heard anybody have this experience
before I put in an offer on this house
it was super cheap because it was like a
short sale you know it was like property
was super cheap obviously right after
the crash and and
um and they sat on the offer for a while
they came back to me like three weeks
later and they said my agent called me
he was like I don't know can't make
heads or tails out of this but the the
the bank wants you is asking if you are
willing to lower your offer by fifty
thousand dollars and if that happens
we'll clear it and you'll get the house
and I did it and I got the house look
absolutely not no I want to pay fifty
thousand dollars more
but I guess the issue was like would the
buyer accept or the seller it was like I
think the best I can make of it is like
there was nobody who actually owned the
house because these were all securitized
loans it was like you know some Chinese
Sovereign wealth fund and you know
pension fund or whatever so nobody
actually had equity in the house but the
bank that was holding the debt on it was
just losing money every month oh that
was on the market so they just wanted it
was a toxic asset they just wanted to
get off the market and what they were
afraid of is if they took the the the
offer that I accepted the appraiser
would come in who used to be super you
know these appraisers used to be super
like corrupt and arm hand in glove with
the with the Realtors but all of a
sudden they were super honest and um and
so they were afraid that the appraiser
was going to come in and say no this is
not worth as much as you're offering and
then the deal would fall part and then
they'd have it on their their books for
months longer so that's the best I can
make sense of it
First Republic said Monday lost a net
total of 72 billion dollars in deposits
during the first quarter an outflow that
would have topped 100 billion if not for
a rescue from 11 of the nation's largest
bank so this is like people are it's a
run in the bank yeah that's this this
sounds like people are rushing to the
the bank and getting their money I'm
worried uh it's kind of scary there's
another story did you guys hear PNC is
shutting down like 40 some odd branches
wow no no dude I wonder if the banking
system is going and we're like on the
Titanic just oblivious is like the
banker system and the media at the same
time we need it Jimmy Stewart dude the
media uh Nate silver got fired yeah
buzzfeed's gone BuzzFeed news
Jimmy Stewart to be like oh the money's
not in the bank it's in your neighbor's
home and in their business so they don't
believe their money there I think the
first thing Adrian you did was like you
looked up Jim Cramer
[Laughter]
he literally said but no you pulled it
up right before the show and you're like
oh he said it's a safe Bank he could be
right like fundamental FRC is new Focus
very good bank
is telling you the man is undefeated he
will not lose I mean I I I'm really
considering using him as an inverse
financial advisor you know what I mean
just like whatever he says you do the
opposite he's like the George Costanza
Finance dude with Nancy Pelosi and Jim
Cramer you should know exactly what to
invest in you have no excuse that's
that's true yeah whatever Nancy Pelosi
invests in and whatever Jim Cramer
advises you to do you do the opposite
he's like don't do he's like Nancy's
headed for bankruptcy you don't invest
in anyone is
I don't know what this means though am I
supposed to be worried like should we
Panic you should always panicked him
I should I should always always Panic
that's a good rule of thumb
I want to try and pull up this news look
at this one this is this is like we
never actually covered this story even
though it's from April 4th what can I
close this or something what is this PNC
Bank set to close 47 branches across the
U.S by end of June wow so uh if you got
First Republic or PNC I guess the
challenging thing is does reporting on
it just contribute to a run on the bank
and like make everything worse I think
yes the banking system though it was a
matter of time because the whole thing
operates on on confidence and Faith
right yeah I mean they have a system of
fractional Reserve lending where if you
put in 100 bucks you know the bank can
lend out 90 of it and only hold 10. yeah
and the only thing that's holding the
system together is everybody not going
to the bank at the same time to take the
money out which is exactly what's
happening right now but they're actually
lend out a hundred they remove the
reserve requirements well they put up
20. I think they put it back someone's
super chatted so they put it back but
it's it's not that they can learn at 90.
it's that they can create ninety dollars
so if there's a hundred dollars in the
bank they create 90 new dollars on that
100 so now there's 190 in the money
supply I thought I thought they could
actually multiply it by 10 right because
they only need 10 in reserve so if they
have a hundred dollars they can create
nine hundred dollars like what happened
with the battle out was the FED issued
out like 425 billion so that could be
leveraged to give 4.2 trillion in loans
out like I I'm not sure my understanding
was that you put 100 in the bank they
create 90 in loans so they still have
the 100 and that's another 90 and then
someone who gets that 90 deposits it
into different bank so now there's 100
here 90 here that bank then loans out
you know uh 80 81 or whatever and so 100
turns into a thousand dollars and that's
inflation yeah no but but I actually
think because you only have to have 10
on hand they can literally say we have a
hundred dollars therefore we're able to
lend out 900 as opposed to 90. I think
you guys are saying the same thing
you're saying no but he said well he's
saying 90. yeah so I'm just being like
they could like loan that 90 out but
they're not loving it out they're
creating it create well yes like crazy
showing money yeah let me resolve this
if somebody puts 100 into a bank they
create
um 900 because they're because that's
ten percent right so that gives them the
ability to be able to I don't think
don't they can loan out 90 of the
deposits oh I hear what you're saying
okay yeah so if they receive a hundred
dollars they keep they cannot hand but
what I'm saying yeah 100 on hand and
then create 90. I think that do they or
do they just actually issue it out
because a lot of these Banks don't have
the cash on hand when people come to
withdraw and that's why they collapse so
I think they actually do pass the money
out no someone's saying it's 900 not 90.
yeah yeah not in the sense 100 deposit
is 1 000 in new money loans yeah if they
lend the money out it's not Sheamus is
right okay
well so anybody else's bank account
though we don't we don't actually fact
we just ask the audience in the audience
yeah the audience says I'm right this is
the popularity yeah I got no idea I mean
I'm not I'm not a finance guy so I just
I'll defer to the cartoonist
that's a brilliant strategy look if you
can make a living making cartoons you're
good with money that's all I'll say even
you can stretch and stretch that dollar
dude it was then an anti-semitic joke
what no it was an anti-media he's Irish
uh no one here is panicking though like
you're like I'm kind of working well you
got hold on you got a house fifty
thousand dollars cheaper right after the
crash so if you get a break but I might
get a free house now oh well that would
be nice yeah what happens like the bank
the government bails out of the
government owns your house I have no
idea what happens what if Joe Biden no I
just like we're on your house it's in
our house man you can't own a house it's
everyone's house man oh man so what he
said about kids today so here's our your
children it's the nation's children I
was like what
excuse me the state owns your kids you
can't tell someone not to sniff your kid
man it's we're all paying taxes for that
hair
I don't think he said that that's
exactly what he said you fact check me
have the chat back check me on it Tim
uh all right chat did Joe Biden actually
say he's allowed to smell your kids I'm
they're gonna say he did that was the
spirit
of what she's saying between the lines
First Republic Bank shares 49 after
earnings report I mean like the
story is I can opine for days on like
ABC News firing Nate Smith I'm sorry
Nate silver and uh BuzzFeed collapsing
and Don Lemon getting fired and Tucker
getting fired but like the banking
system collapsing I'm kind of just like
well I'm glad I bought Bitcoin or
something I don't know it's like as a
millennial who's lived through two major
Financial crises I'm kind of not phased
by Banks falling apart and what that
means and especially considering you
know I got chickens so I'm I'm not I'm
not worried about it are you confident
in Bitcoin
yeah yeah well I'm more confident in the
chickens to be honest that's true though
I I am more confident in the chickens
what do you make of the idea that that
crypto is actually the vehicle that's
going to be used to bring in the cbdcs I
mean it is that literally is what
they're doing like this the Central
Bank digital currencies are crypto based
currencies that they're they're making
the Bitcoin of course the precursor but
I've actually argued this for a while
that Bitcoin was the most convenient way
to get anti-establishment conspiracy
type individuals to embrace Global
Currency you have people like Alex Jones
being locked I want a One World
Government with one currency Romero the
Euro and then all of a sudden around the
time he's complaining about the Amero an
American single North American single
currency Bitcoin pops up no one knows
who made it and then immediately it's
all of these people who want to buy it
so it's like convince the one group of
people who would reject a Global
Currency to to adopt the Global Currency
and you've won you've you've controlled
that position your way through the the
barricade you know yeah well and this is
part of what is very confusing right I
mean conservatism doesn't have a solid
definition or solid footing at the
present moment it's a little bit of
we're just gonna do the opposite of what
the left is doing and a little bit of
we're just going to do the opposite of
what the establishment is doing the idea
of Bitcoin is certainly not a
conservative idea right that's a very
new interesting Innovative idea it
doesn't make it a bad one I think there
could be value to it but what
conservatism is supposed to be about
conserving yeah I would say it's more of
a return and it's not to say that
conservatives can't have any thinking
which overlaps with libertarianism and
it would be reasonable to say because
this government is so horrible and does
things so badly and as it's drawing our
currency it makes sense for
conservatives to look into crypto if
that's the particular hedge they've
chosen this is not Financial advice
but we have not we don't have a
cohesively defined movement well I guess
we'll see what happens with these Banks
and um I'm not going to give anybody
Financial advice but I'll just tell you
I've I'm I've already been looking at
means of storing value elsewhere because
with PNC closing I think it was a 47
branches that's very scary you know I
mean that's like that might be bigger
news than a Regional Bank collapsing
because PNC is a major Bank they're
they're all over the East Coast
maybe 47 is not that many compared to
how many branches they have I guess it's
an important question but all of this
happening at once it's kind of the thing
about Silicon Valley and First Republic
is that they're like high-end banks for
you know affluent people they do like
first Republicans main business is
wealth management so I don't know about
PNC because we don't I don't think I
guess we do have it on the West Coast
but it's not very very present is it no
they're just like normal people yeah
they're like Wawa and stuff like that
right right so I don't know what
conclusions draw from the fact that it's
these like Elite banks that are falling
but in Australia they announced that
some of their big banks are going to
stop giving out cash
you go to the bank you're like I like
money like you can't have it yup yeah
and the reason why is they said it's
because everyone's using mobile apps so
nobody needs the physical location to
withdraw cash anymore he's got an ATM
which is the precursor to your money
only exists on the internet yeah and
then Central Bank digital currency I've
actually wondered many times what that
what this means for panhandlers
you're gonna have nobody cares cash
anymore right you're gonna tap your card
you're going to walk up and go and then
they're going to be alive thank you sir
and you're like they're gonna hold out
the keypad and you're gonna go through
and you're gonna type in the number
that's actually actually interesting I
wonder if like the global Elites are
trying to eliminate that kind of thing
panhandling I mean maybe you'll hand
them a bottle of water or a sandwich
well in my city there are sometimes
homeless people who have like a cash app
thing out on their site yeah
there are a lot of homeless people who
just have like really cheap smartphones
nowadays so they get seriously they'll
get like a 20 phone from qriket or
something or whatever the inexpensive
phone uh YouTube is now you're talking
about down in Georgia yeah yeah so
you're saying I could go to a big city
and just sit in a lawn chair and put up
a sign with a cash up and say give me
money and then people will just send me
money yeah you look the roll we should
you know we should do we should put a
cash app thing on on timcast like right
down here in the corner and just like
speaking of questions please give me
your money I know this isn't on the
docket but did you guys read this report
it was like a month ago or something
about how cash app and the entire what's
the name of it it's not Square anymore
it's like Cube or something like that
whatever the company is Jack dorsey's
company I think it's still square is it
still Square yeah cuberson might be a
different one okay the the entire
um app is basically like most of its
Revenue comes from like sex trafficking
drug deal oh my God wait wait Jack
dorsey's way what it was like it was a
very exhaustive report about how cash
app is just built straight up on Black
Market activity we have to make cash app
safe for the black market which is why
we're banning all legal activity on
Crash so wait wait wait cash app
where did you find this it was this
report that was issued that they took
issue with but the report was very
detailed I read a lot of it um uh it was
exhaustive I didn't read the whole thing
because I I I've got Square shares you
know I got a handful of them yeah you
should read that report oh yeah it was
like I don't know it was maybe like 10
years ago or something or eight years
ago someone told me this Rich dude who
lived in New York I was hanging out with
Max Kaiser and he was just like you got
to buy Square stock because everything's
going digital transactions and I was
like okay I guess and then I bought a
little bit and then it like went tenfold
in value I was like wow the other thing
I remember in this report is that
there's all these rappers who are
straight up bragging about it in their
raps so they're like they're like
another thing that it funds is a lot of
like um like Hitmen are hired via cash
app and there's these rappers who like
some of whom have been charged with
murder after say after reciting these
lyrics who are like hit me on cash app
and they're talking about like doing
hits on people oh my gosh so it's like
it's like in the and then Jack Dorsey I
think I remember from this report at one
point was like in an interview was
talking about how grateful he is to all
the the publicity he's gotten from these
from these rappers
oh my gosh this is the guy who thinks
that using the offensive pronouns for
person on Twitter makes them unsafe and
he's like come here's my murder app
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time